nous passons donc à l'ordre du jour qui
appelle le débat sur les finances
locales une demande de la commission des
finances la parole est tout d'abord aux
orateurs de la commission qui a demandé
ce débat en commençant par Monsieur
Vincent et blé vice-président de la
commission des finances je serai un peu
intransigeant sur les temps de parole de
ce débat parce que nous avons pris un
peu de retard et il faut respecter
les conditions du débat de la séance de
ce soir donc nous serons tenir dans les
temps et je serai stricte sur les temps
de parole donc monsieur le Président
nous sommes contraints avant et après
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues la loi organique
relative à la gestion des finances
publiques nous permet aujourd'hui en
amont de la discussion du projet de loi
de finance de consacrer l'organisation
d'un débat à la situation des finances
locales nous sommes tous d'accord pour
dire que cet exercice est bien venu
madame la ministre vous souhaitez
supprimer la c.be sur deux ans pour
soi-disant améliorer la compétitivité de
nos entreprises industrielles pour
autant cette suppression de
bénéficierait qu'à hauteur de 40% à ces
dernières et bénéficierait par contre à
nombre de sociétés du secteur tertiaire
avec la suppression de la CVAE vous ne
ciblez pas les entreprises industrielles
tant qu'à vouloir soutenir la
compétitivité de notre industrie ne
faudrait-il pas mieux conserver ses
moyens pour faire face à la crise
énergétique qui la touche de plein fouet
par ailleurs la compensation proposée
inclus deux années de crise sanitaire où
nous avons observé une contraction du
produit de la CVAE pourtant l'État a
déjà perçu le montant de la CVE 2023 qui
lui est dynamique la ficelle est assez
grossière pour ne pas fâcher les
bénéficiaires ainsi laisser
la première ministre c'est certes
engagée à abonder ponctuellement le
nouveau fond vert du montant de cette
dynamique de 2023 mais il n'affecte pas
le socle de la compensation de la CVAE
cela revient donc à diminuer la somme
fixée pour cette compensation les
incidences du schéma de compensation sur
les indicateurs financiers des
collectivités qui n'interviendrait
certes qu'à compter de 2024 n'ont pas à
ce jour été évalués ni leurs
conséquences ni le cas échéant corrigé
sur ce point à l'heure actuelle le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 ce
borne un renvoi bien trop large au
pouvoir réglementaire cela me rappelle
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
ou des problèmes de compensation
subsiste notamment sur la réforme des
indicateurs financiers vous vous
attaquez au sujet de la CVE alors que
celui de la TH n'est pas clos
auparavant avec les contrats de Cahors
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau pacte de
confiance vous souhaitez opérer le
mouvement visant à recentraliser le
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs je note que cet
article a été supprimé à l'Assemblée
nationale pourquoi a-t-il été supprimé
parce qu'il était irréaliste il
établissait le plafonnement de la
progression des dépenses de
fonctionnement à un niveau inférieur
d'un demi point au niveau de l'inflation
des sanctions étaient même prévues en
cas de dépassement cela ne me semble pas
acceptable surtout que l'on ne connaît
ni les critères ni l'organisation
précise de ces nouveaux dispositifs
coercitifs madame la ministre votre
copie est à revoir il convient de sortir
de l'air du soupçon vis-à-vis de nos
élus locaux d'autant plus qu'ils sont
contraints par des règles budgétaires
bien plus exigeantes que celle qui
s'applique à l'état et au gouvernement
et madame la ministre je voudrais le
dire cela se voit
pour respecter vos engagements européens
vous souhaitez faire des économies sur
le dos des collectivités qui sont plus
vertueuses que vous face à la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie de nombreuses
collectivités même celles en bonne santé
financière se voit dans l'obligation de
décaler des travaux importants ou des
projets d'investissement en particulier
ceux en faveur de la transition et
énergétique madame la ministre votre
seul souci devrait être de permettre aux
collectivités de conserver une épargne
brute significative afin de couvrir des
investissements nouveaux surtout que la
facture énergétique pour les
collectivités est estimée à 11 milliards
d'euros selon le rapport de notre
collègue Gatel le bouclier est tarifaire
ainsi que le plafonnement des prix de
l'électricité à 180 euros le mégawatts
sont certes utiles mais ne répondrons
que de manière
insatisfaisante à l'augmentation des
charges des collectivités oui
ces collectivités peuvent participer à
l'effort de redressement de nos comptes
publics mais il doit d'abord y avoir un
échange constructif avec les
associations d'élus souvenons-nous que
les contes des collectivités
territoriales ne peuvent être en
déséquilibre
actuellement les finances locales
connaissent un effet ciseaux du fait
d'une forte progression des dépenses non
compensées par une augmentation
équivalente de leur recette madame la
ministre le processus de mitage fiscal
organisé méthodiquement transforme peu à
peu les principaux impôts directs locaux
en compensation puis en dotation
compensation et dotation sur lesquelles
les élus locaux exercent ni pouvoir
d'auto ni pouvoir d'assiette au regard
du contexte actuel l'enjeu majeur
aujourd'hui est une meilleure
coordination des finances locales
sociales et éthiques plutôt que laisser
s'engager un retour vers un idéal d'État
central qui ne peut et ne doit plus être
merci
merci monsieur le Président et la parole
est maintenant à Madame Christine
Labarde Vice-Présidente de la commission
des finances pour 5 minutes également
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
j'interviens donc au nom du rapporteur
général Jean-François Husson qui ne
pouvait être présent ce soir dans les
mystique ce débat sur la situation des
finances des collectivités territoriales
représentent une avancée importante
parmi par la réforme de la Golf et à
laquelle leur rapporteur général tenait
particulièrement pour cadrer ce débat un
premier constat s'impose il faut
d'emblée dissiper l'illusion d'une
situation financière favorable pour les
collectivités territoriales au-delà de
leur grande hétérogénéité raisonnée à
partir de moyenne globale n'a pas grand
sens qu'elle est donc cette réalité tout
d'abord fin 2021 près de 46% des
communes disposées d'une épargne brute
encore inférieure à leur niveau 2019 la
crise sanitaire a laissé des traces
budgétaires pour de très nombreuses
collectivités frapper désormais par les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
une première réponse a été apportée cet
été avec l'adoption un loi de finance
rectificative d'un filet de sécurité
pour le bloc communal et de mesures
spécifiques pour les départements et les
régions ce filet de sécurité le fruit
d'un travail entre les différents
groupes de l'Assemblée nationale que le
Sénat a renforcé de façon significative
on y incluant les charges liées au
relèvement du point d'indice de la
fonction publique à la hausse du prix de
l'énergie mais aussi à la forte
inflation sur les produits alimentaires
ce dispositif a le mérite d'exister pour
préserver les collectivités qui auront
été le plus en difficulté en 2022 pour
autant sa portée n'est plus adaptée en
effet la situation continue de se
dégrader depuis la rentrée de nombreuses
collectivités voient se dresser un mur
lors du renouvellement de leur contrat
de fourniture d'électricité et de gaz et
ne savent pas à ce stade comment
équilibrer leur budget pour l'année
prochaine des mesures puissantes et
efficaces doivent être prises dans le
projet de loi de finances pour protéger
les collectivités qui ont non besoin le
gouvernement doit comprendre quand les
laissant dans cette impasse financière
nous agissons contre notre propre
intérêt en effet ce sont elles les
collectivités qui ont la capacité de
mener dans nos territoires les projets
d'investissement indispensables en
particulier ceux qui permettront de
mettre en œuvre et de réussir au plus
près des besoins la transition
écologique indispensable à notre pays
Miss débats ne doit pas se limiter aux
épreuves de l'année à venir l'examen du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
2027 nous donne notamment l'occasion de
nous prononcer globalement sur la
stratégie de redressement des comptes
publics et en particulier sur la juste
part que doivent prendre les
collectivités territoriales dans cet
effort bien que leur solde soit
excédentaire de près de 5 milliards
d'euros en 2021 et que lors d'être
représente moins de 9% de la dette
publique totale le gouvernement fait le
choix de demander aux collectivités
territoriales un effort très substantiel
de baisse de leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement de 0,5 sans parents en
volume dans le même temps si l'on
neutralise l'effet des dépenses du plan
d'urgence du plan de relance et plus
globalement les dépenses de crise il
apparaît que l'État ne réaliserait pas
le moindre effort sur ses dépenses et
que même celle-ci progresser sur la
période de programmation sans aucun
doute notre assemblée comme les élus
locaux ne sauraient accepter sans réagir
les méthodes d'un État qui entend
réduire la dette publique tout en
continuant d'aggraver la sienne ou
encore baisser les impôts en supprimant
ceux des autres la proposition de
suppression de la CVAE et à cet égard
une nouvelle illustration en conclusion
de son propos le rapporteur général
souhaité évoquer le prétendu pacte de
confiance on nous affirme que les
mesures prévues n'ont rien à voir avec
les contrats de Cahors il faut donc
croire que c'est par retour de riz que
le gouvernement a laissé dans l'article
23 du projet de LPF qui nous est
présenté plusieurs paragraphes
entièrement copier coller depuis
l'article 29 de la précédente loi de
programmation qui institué des contrats
de Cahors alors certes une première
année de liberté surveillée est accordée
avant la mise en oeuvre d'un mécanisme
de correction extrêmement contraignant
appliquée au terme d'un raisonnement par
strate de collectivité pour le moins
d'aoûteux de nouvelles fonctions par
ailleurs été imaginées avec notamment
l'exclusion des dotations des
investissements de l'État nous sommes
vous le voyez bien loin de là nouvelle
méthode qui nous avait été annoncée les
collectivités territoriales savent
pourtant pertinemment qu'il existe entre
elle et l'État une communauté de destins
et que la réussite de notre pays passe
par le redressement de ses finances
publiques elles ont consenti de très
importants et forts par le passé pour
maîtriser leurs dépenses et sont prêts à
continuer à le faire sous réserve de
réciprocités de la part de l'État c'est
une question de justice au-delà des mots
nous attendons donc plus que des actes
mais des actes de confiance bien sûr
bien merci et la parole est maintenant à
Madame Caroline cailleux ministre
délégué chargé des collectivités
territoriales pour 10 minutes maximum
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
vice-président de la commission des
finances madame la vice-président de la
commission des finances mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'est un plaisir et un honneur de
prendre part avec vous à ce premier
débat consacré au finances locales ce
nouvel outil démocratique a été rendu
possible par la loi organique du 28
décembre 2021 relative à la
modernisation de la gestion des finances
publiques il constitue selon moi une
avancée pour notre pays pour nos
collectivités en introduisant de manière
inédite un temps dédié aux finances
locales dans le cours de l'examen des
projets de loi de finances j'ai déjà pu
me livrer cet exercice vendredi dernier
à l'Assemblée nationale avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal et comme le veut
le fonctionnement nos institutions c'est
aujourd'hui au Sénat chambre des
territoires que j'ai l'opportunité de me
livrer à nouveau dans des modalités
légèrement différentes
nous avons bien suivi une méthode
renouvelée avec Gabriel Attal et
Christophe déchu dans les laboration du
volet territorial de ce projet de loi de
finances conformément d'ailleurs à la
volonté du Président de la République et
à la première ministre notre démarche a
été celle d'un échange continu en amont
avec les associations des lus pour
co-construire ensemble des mesures qui
répondent aux besoins des territoires et
aux attentes de nos concitoyens nous les
avons toutes reçus à plusieurs reprises
jusqu'à la présentation du PLF au Comité
des finances locales le 26 septembre
quelques heures après sa présentation en
conseil des ministres après le temps de
la concertation nous sommes désormais
entrés dans le temps de la construction
la construction d'un budget protecteur
bien sûr mais aussi un budget qui
prennent en compte l'impératif de
maîtrise de nos finances publiques et la
participation indispensable de chacun à
cet effort
cet esprit de responsabilité et c'est
impératif d'action ont été nos deux
guides dans la conception de ce projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 et je le
sais ce sont les deux principes qui
animeront également votre examen
face à la progression inédite de
l'inflation et à l'envoler des coups de
l'énergie les défis auxquels les
collectivités territoriales doivent
faire face impose un soutien accru de
l'État dès cet été je voudrais rappeler
que notre gouvernement a proposé des
mesures fortes dans la loi de finances
rectificative que vous avez d'ailleurs
ici au Sénat enrichi et voté avec
notamment la mise en place d'un filet de
sécurité de 430 millions d'euros pour
aider les communes et les
intercommunalités les plus fragiles à
faire face à la hausse du point d'indice
à la hausse du coût de l'alimentation et
de l'énergie nous savons que certaines
collectivités ont besoin de cette aide
au plus vite c'est pourquoi comme l'a
annoncé Gabriel Attal dès l'apparition
du décret du 13 octobre et jusqu'au 15
novembre les collectivités pourront
déposer leurs demandes qui leur
permettra d'obtenir un acompte de 50%
versé avant le 15 décembre
nous avons par ailleurs à louer 120
millions d'euros au département qui
versent le revenu de solidarité active
pour compenser intégralement la hausse
de 4% de cette prestation prévue par
l'État et nous avons instauré le
recouvrement total par l'État auprès des
régions de la hausse de 4% des
rémunérations des stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle
cet accompagnement de l'État est encore
accentué dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances pour 2023 avec d'abord un
amendement du rapporteur général du
budget à l'Assemblée nationale de
prolongation du filet de sécurité pour
les dépenses énergétiques de 2023 avec
aussi la prolongation du bouclier
tarifaire une mesure qui permettra de
limiter à 15% la hausse des prix de
l'électricité pour 80% des communes
aussi et j'ajouterai le quintuplement de
l'enveloppe à destination des communes
en grande difficulté qui atteint lui 10
millions d'euros et puis surtout le nom
plafonnement des bases fiscales afin de
laisser toute l'autonomie aux
collectivités sur leur dynamique fiscale
ces mesures permettront collectivités de
faire face aux surcoût financiers dans
l'immédiat mais il nous faudra agir
aussi à d'autres échelles à l'échelle
européenne d'abord en cherchant au
niveau du marché européen de l'énergie à
réguler les prix et à capter les supers
profits engendrés chez les grands
groupes énergétiques par cette situation
de tension et aussi chacun à notre
échelle en suivant les recommandations
formulées par la première ministre dans
le plan de sobriété
mais résoudre durablement la crise que
nous connaissons impose aussi d'opérer
des changements profonds de notre modèle
en favorisant la transition écologique
et la transition énergétique dans tous
les territoires
c'est pourquoi le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 prévoit d'augmenter
d'un tiers les moyens consacrés à la
dotation biodiversité pour 2023 qui
avait déjà été doublé en 2022 pour
atteindre un montant de 30 millions
d'euros et puis de mettre en oeuvre un
fond vert d'un montant inédit de près de
2 milliards d'euros pour la méthode
d'attribution de ce fond le financement
se fera selon des règles simples
décentralisées et sans appel à projet
tout partira des initiatives des élus
selon une méthode lisible et reconnue
celle des dialogues entre les élus et
leur préfet de départements ou de région
la première ministre a par ailleurs eu
l'occasion d'annoncer vendredi dernier
que 200 millions d'euros seront
spécifiquement alloués au département
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales c'est avant tout leur
donner les moyens d'agir en sécurisant
leur financement pour leur donner de la
visibilité sur le long terme ainsi avec
la première ministre nous avons souhaité
porter une hausse de la DGF d'un montant
de 320 millions d'euros de la DSU et de
la DSR qui seraient financé par l'État
et non par écrittement des autres
communes cette augmentation est inédite
depuis 3-13 ans et je considère que
c'est un acte fort du gouvernement la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises quant à
elle permettra à notre pays de gagner en
compétitivité sans un moindre rire les
ressources des collectivités elle sera
en effet intégralement compensée et
territorialisée par l'attribution d'une
part supplémentaire de TVA mais aussi de
cette dynamique des 2023 la compensation
l'année prochaine correspondra aux que
l'État aurait dû reverser aux
collectivités en 2023 au titre de la
CVAE il n'y aura pas d'année blanche
rien ne sera conservé par l'État j'ai
dit elle serait territorialisée ce qui
accueillent davantage d'activités seront
davantage compensées sur la base de
critères précisés dans un décret en
Conseil d'État un travail est d'ailleurs
en cours à ce sujet avec les
associations d'élus et ce sujet comme
sur les autres l'écoute et la
concertation devront primer notre souci
de protéger les marges de manœuvre des
collectivités transparaît enfin dans le
maintien de leur dotation
d'investissement à un montant de près de
2 milliards d'euros comme l'année
précédente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voici les principaux éléments des
concours de l'État aux collectivité en
2023 devant les défis qui sont les
nôtres notre pays nos collectivités ne
manquent pas d'atouts et nous avons
toujours su construire au cours de notre
histoire dans ces situations de crise
des consensus responsables au service de
l'intérêt général je sais que ce sera
une nouvelle fois le cas car au-delà du
débat démocratique indispensable nous
espérons que les postures et les effets
de manche qui ne font plus illusions aux
français n'auront pas lieu il ne
satisferont pas d'une nouvelle
représentation du sein peternèment
rejoué du combat entre les montagnards
et les Girondins ces collectivement que
les Français nous jugeront sur notre
bilan nous réussites et notre capacité à
améliorer concrètement leurs qualités de
vie merci pour votre attention
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
du débat donc la parole est maintenant à
Hervé Moret pour l'Union centriste pour
4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues après le quinquennat
de François Hollande caractérisé par une
baisse drastique des dotations à hauteur
de 11 milliards d'euros Emmanuel Macron
lors de son accession à la présidence de
la République en 2017 a voulu donner des
assurances aux collectivités locales en
matière financière ainsi l'annonce d'une
stabilisation du niveau de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement a été
accueilli favorablement
malheureusement la désillusion fut
rapide car dès l'été qui a suivi la
nomination du gouvernement en 2017
celui-ci a pris un certain nombre de
décisions dont je rappelle les
principales la réduction de 300 millions
d'euros de crédit dédiés aux
collectivités locales la suppression de
la réserve parlementaire et la quasi
suppression des emplois aidés quant à la
DGF si son montant a bien été stabilisé
globalement la réalité de chaque commune
est tout autre puisque pour la moitié
des communes de France
les dotations ont en fait diminué au
cours des cinq dernières années
les collectivités locales ont également
vu leur levier fiscaux considérablement
réduit par les réformes fiscales qui se
poursuivent aujourd'hui au détriment de
leur autonomie financière
dans le même temps les collectivités
locales ont eu à faire face à deux chocs
sans précédent celui de la crise
sanitaire est celui de l'inflation le
choc la crise sanitaire a coûté 7
milliards d'euros aux collectivités dont
3,2 milliards au bloc communal sur les
3,4 milliards de pertes de recettes le
bloc communal ne s'est vu compenser qu'à
hauteur de 270 millions d'euros les
pertes de recettes fiscales et
domaniales et de 250 millions d'euros au
titre du dispositif d'aide au SPIC et au
spa à présent c'est au choc de
l'inflation que les collectivités
locales doivent faire face je
rappellerai madame la ministre que j'ai
attiré l'attention du gouvernement dès
le mois de février sur les conséquences
de l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
à l'époque sans aucune écoute de la part
du gouvernement
le gouvernement a renforcé ce choc en
juillet en augmentant le point d'indice
pour un surcoût de 2,3 milliards d'euros
le gouvernement n'est pas jugé utile
contrairement à ce que j'ai cru entendre
de votre part de prévoir un dispositif
de compensation pour les collectivités
c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui a
introduit un filet de sécurité
extrêmement limité et que nous avons au
Sénat considérablement amélioré
notamment aux apports grâce aux apports
du groupe de l'Union centriste auquel
t'appartenir
ce filet de sécurité reste toutefois
très limité il devrait en effet
bénéficier seulement à 5 à 8000 communes
ou groupement et en 2023 seulement alors
que c'est aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des
communes ont à faire face à ces surcos
ce dispositif pose question et je
souhaiterais que ce débat puisse nous
éclairer sur le système d'avance prévu
quelle commune vont en bénéficier quand
et comment vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la nécessité de déposer un
dossier mais la plupart des communes ne
savent même pas si elles peuvent
prétendre à se filer de sécurité donc je
crois qu'il y a vraiment besoin de
clarification et nous serions très
heureux de vous entendre sur ce point
concernant le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 dont nous reparlerons à notre
grande surprise celui-ci ne prévoyait
pas dans sa version déposée à
l'Assemblée nationale de prolonger ce
filet de sécurité et l'augmentation de
320 millions annoncés par la première
ministre est présentée comme une
première depuis 13 ans je cite
représente en réalité une revalorisation
d'une revalorisation de 1 de 2% du
montant total de la DGF quand
l'inflation est de plus de 5%. nous
sommes bien loin de l'indexation de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
demandée par les associations d'études
vous l'aurez compris madame la ministre
les élus est plus particulièrement les
mers sont inquiets des perspectives
financières pour leur collectivité et
j'ajouterai que en plus dans le contexte
de transfert de la taxe d'aménagement à
l'intercommunalité il y a des situations
qui sont particulièrement compliquées je
rappelle que ce dispositif a été voté
par l'Assemblée nationale sans aucune
concertation il faudra que l'on en
reparle lors de l'examen de projet de
loi de finance aussi madame la minis je
ne peux que vous appelez à revoir la
copie du projet du prochain projet pour
permettre aux collectivités de faire
face à cette période particulièrement
difficile
merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenant à notre collègue Stéphane
Ravier
sénateurs non inscrits
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues y a-t-il encore une
décentralisation dans notre pays la
question mérite d'être posée car si l'on
décentralise les compétences la
fiscalité elle reste jacobine ce
gouvernement fait preuve de la démo
démagogie fiscale sur le dos des
collectivités territoriales on a osé
parler de suppression de la taxe
d'habitation mais rien n'est supprimé
pour le contribuable les propriétaires
supportent la hausse de la taxe foncière
et les locataires la hausse des loyers
qui en découlent avec la suppression de
la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises les communes finissent de
perdre toute autonomie fiscale peu de
ressources propres et plus de ressources
réellement dynamiques prise au piège à
son contrainte de racketter les
propriétaires en augmentant la taxe
foncière avec la hausse du prix de
l'énergie à plus de 250% la flambée des
matières premières de la restauration
scolaire et l'augmentation du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires les communes
n'ont plus de marge de manœuvre en ce
moment les mers et leurs adjoints au
finance sont dans la préparation de leur
budget pour 2023 il s'arrache les
cheveux ils font face à une explosion de
leur budget de fonctionnement pourtant
cela fait depuis le printemps dernier
que je demande au gouvernement un
bouclier tarifaire sur les prix de
l'énergie pour les collectivités en vain
c'était cet été on a eu droit en pleine
canicule à la fermeture de piscine comme
dans les bougies-rhône à Cabriès et cet
hiver on risque la suppression des
décorations et faite de Noël et pendant
ce temps l'état obèse refuse de
descendre de notre dos et de sortir ses
mains de nos poches la crise qui
s'installe montre encore l'inefficacité
de l'État et la pertinence de la gestion
locale mais le gouvernement ne veut rien
entendre l'état répond par des soins
palliatifs à la fixie des collectivités
locales des aides et des hausses de
dotation mais plus de ressources propres
et comme il reste tributaire du bon
vouloir de Bercy et en sont réduites à
faire la manche la Banque Postale
prévoit une baisse de 11,3% de leur
épargne brute cette année en 2023 il ne
faudra que quelques mois pour que les
communes aient épuisées la totalité de
leur budget de fonctionnement sans
changement nous allons vers un blackout
fiscal communal la Cour des comptes dans
son rapport de la semaine dernière
propose que les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux soit recentrés sur le bloc
communal voilà une proposition qui
permettrait aux communes de retrouver
une ressource dynamique ce serait
injuste retour de leur investissement
constant pour l'attractivité du
territoire qui leur permettrait
notamment de financer leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement
décentralisé la fiscalité c'est garantir
le principe constitutionnel de
consentement à l'impôt de nos
concitoyens qui compte à des pieds dans
le réel comprendra que c'est un enjeu
majeur rendre commune leur autonomie
fiscale c'est à ça et à rien d'autre que
nous devons travailler mes chers
collègues
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Jean-Claude Riquier pour le
groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
[Musique]
monsieur madame le rapporteur général
de la commission des finances mais ça
collègue je tiens en premier lieu à
saluer la tenue se débat instauré par la
loi organique de mondialisation de la
question des finances publiques adoptée
à la fin de l'année dernière c'est une
nouvelle loi organique contribue à
difficile tâches de moderniser le cadre
des lois des finances certains envisagé
restauration du noir spécifique pour
référence au cas les stars de la loi sur
le financement de la sécurité sociale
nous se contentons aujourd'hui d'un
débat mais les enjeux politiques des
différents locales conjuguées à une
technicité de plus en plus complexe rend
sans doute inévitable à terme la
discussion d'un texte budgétaire
spécifique
le dernier rapport à la Cour des comptes
sa situation des finances locales est
éclairant en particulier dans les
comparaisons internationales les
finances locales ne représentent en
France que 20% dans l'espace public un
niveau inférieur à la moyenne européenne
ou les dépenses les dépenses des
collectivités locales représentent
plutôt 40 % de cette espace public avec
des modèles éthiques et des périmètres
de compétences certes différents
néanmoins cela revient en perspective un
débat ou les collectivités se voient
toujours reprochées manque de rigueur
budgétaire alors qu'elles sont les seuls
à présenter chaque année un soldat
l’équilibre si les collectivités
représentent donc un cinquième la
dépasse unique elles ont une
contribution casinue au déficit public
au-delà de ces considérations
la situation financière des
collectivités est évidemment très
diverses globalement voire
paradoxalement les collectivités sont
sorties de la crise sanitaire avait
définiances plus saines qu'avant la
crise grâce aux économies qui ont été
réalisées et aux jeunes accordées le
gouvernement toutefois c'est la cage des
situations individuelles très
contrastées je concentrerai mon propos
sur les finances communales et celles et
départements le bloc communal a été le
plus affecté par les dernières réformes
la fiscalité suppression d'attaque
d'habitation sur les réseaux principales
et bientôt suppression complète de la
céréale si tire encore aujourd'hui les
deux tiers de ses ressources de la
fiscalité locale même si celle-ci tant
être remplacé par un transfert d'impôts
nationaux la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui et bien sûr celle de
l'autonomie financière alors que la
différenciation territoriale devient un
enjeu politique majeur cette question
concerne si les départements davantage
financé par les impôts nationaux et les
dotations ils font face à une montée en
puissance de leurs interventions dans
domaine social je pense en particulier
au département ruraux souvent des prises
démographiques appelées à accompagner le
vieillissement de la population avec des
ressources fiscales propres à dynamique
bien sûr la solidarité nationale doit
jouer grâce au transfert d'impôts
d'impôts nationaux mais là aussi ce
poids de la question de la soutenabilité
d'un modèle de centralisation on accepte
de différencier voire de donner à terme
un pouvoir réglementaire d'adaptation
mais sans donner une véritable autonomie
financière correspondant à l'autonomie
décision bien sûr face au retour de
l'inflation le gouvernement a pris en
loi de finance rectificative des mesures
qui ont aidé les collectivités à faire
face et que je salue avec une robe 430
millions d'euros visa à compenser la
hausse des prix énergétiques et la
revalorisation du point d'Indy des
fonctionnaires néanmoins je vous
apprends pas l'inquiétude des élus pour
2023 qui souhaitent que ce soutien soit
pérennisé en loi de finance les
avantages
la semaine dernière Sam le confirmer ce
dont je me réjouis mon groupe soutiendra
dans tous les cas les mesures visent à
donner
les moyens correspondent à leur mission
dont on sait qu'elles sont
indispensables à notre cohésion sociale
quoi qu'il en soit la principale mesure
du projet des lois de finance pour 2023
et bien évidemment la suppression en
deux ans de la resta de la CVAE cette
compensation par le versement d'une
fraction de TVA est annoncée à l'Europe
pérenne et dynamique nous prenons au
moment de la ministre il veilleront dans
l'état c'est agissant par ailleurs d'une
façon de l'État le gouvernement poursuit
sa politique du président quinquennat
marqué par une grande stabilité la DGF
reste proche de 26 à 27 milliards
d'euros malgré l'inflation les montagnes
de nations de péréquation comme la
dsuadr seront revalorisés dans les mêmes
montants que les années précédentes à
l'état actuel des débats sur le projet
loi de finance il reste toutefois
difficile d'entrevoir l'architecture
financière qui sortira pour les
collectivités dans l'attente de la mise
en oeuvre de l'article 49-3 dont on
parle beaucoup
et l'incertitude demeure comme elle
illustre les débats chaotiques autour du
projet de loi de finance de
programmation 2023 2027 au vu du
contexte et chronique et social que
traverse notre pays les collectivités
territoriales comme tous nos concitoyens
ont besoin de clarté de prévisibilité et
de sérieux
merci au président Riquet et la parole
est maintenant président karucci pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
le débat essentiel c'est de se demander
si nous respectons depuis un certain
temps la Constitution
dans les articles 72 à 74 on nous
explique longuement ce qu'est
l'autonomie des collectivités en quoi
est-ce que l'autonomie des collectivités
vous n'y êtes pour rien madame la
ministre et respecter quand on supprime
progressivement la taxe professionnelle
la taxe d'habitation la CVAE lorsqu'on
met en place un encadrement d'État alors
ça s'appelle un coup les accords ou le
pack de Cahors plus belle pack de
confiance et puis plein de pactes plein
de pactes mais une seule réalité les
élus locaux perdent le pouvoir
les élus locaux perdent la capacité
d'agir sur leur territoire parce que ils
perdent la capacité de financer alors
vous allez me dire et vous l'avez dit
vous-même madame la ministre on compense
oui mais c'est pas la même chose
centraliser recentraliser l'impôt pour
ensuite faire en sorte que les
collectivités dépendent de dotation
d'État qui ne sont assez rarement
remises au niveau de l'inflation ça
n'est pas la même chose ça revient à
dire qu'en réalité la gestion des élus
locaux et si peu fiable qu'il faut la
recentraliser et que c'est l'état et son
administration d'État qui part
définition est bien plus douée que les
élus locaux qui doivent gérer le tout
alors il y a un vrai problème moi je me
souviens très bien ici même de Jean-Marc
Ayrault Premier ministre qui fin 2012
nous avait dit l'année prochaine nous
remettrons à plat l'ensemble de la
fiscalité nationale et locale et nous
allons enfin trouver un équilibre
inutile de dire que nous n'avons jamais
eu cette table ronde jamais cette remise
à plat et que les gouvernements quel
qu'il soit depuis 20 ans continue très
progressivement de rogner le pouvoir des
élus locaux
les mers aujourd'hui sont à la fois
étranglés sont responsables devant la
population et non plus la capacité de
leur responsabilité et c'est ça le vrai
problème vous ne pouvez pas être madame
le ministre vous étiez maire de Beauvais
il y a encore peu et vous savez très
bien que lorsque pendant le mandat de
Hollande on réduisait les dotations
lorsque ici ou là on nous a dit
suppression de la taxe d'habitation sans
forcément de négociation et bien il y a
une perte de pouvoir des élus locaux il
y a une perte de capacité d'action il y
a une perte de réalité du lien entre la
population les collectivités locales et
leurs élus je viens de voir j'espère que
ça ne va pas prospérer que même sur la
taxe foncière un amendement a été voté à
la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale pour fixer un
maximum de hausse de la taxe foncière en
disant que au-delà et bien l'état
compenserait même sur la taxe foncière
alors bientôt il y aura plus aucune
ressource des collectivités locales et
on attendra que l'état veuille bien
donner un minimum pour survivre ça n'est
pas ça l'autonomie et je vous rappelle
que la Cour des comptes dit elle-même
que effectivement au fur et à mesure des
années l'autonomie des collectivités
locales et remise en cause je regrette
que la Cour des comptes n'aie pas plus
loin en demandant clairement à l'état de
cesser cette ce mouvement ce mouvement
qui dure depuis 20 ans qui consiste à
faire en sorte que les collectivités
locales soient de plus en plus
dépendantes de l'État et de moins en
moins dépendante de leur projet locaux
de leur population de la volonté de
leurs élus alors tout ça est dans un
contexte totalement fou parce que
effectivement avec les crises on l'a dit
crise sanitaire la crise énergétique
tout le monde essaye de trouver des
solutions et nos collectivités vont
clairement trinquer il faut dire les
choses s'il y a pas de bouclier
énergétique sur les collectivités s'il y
a pas une capacité à trouver une
solution vraiment acceptable sur la CVAE
s'il n'y a pas de capacité à dire à
toutes les collectivités pas vous l'avez
dit madame la ministre vous dites 80%
des communes seront concernées et les
20% autres pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas totalement une capacité à dire on va
faire en sorte que les collectivités
locales puissent exister que les élus
locaux retrouvent leur pouvoir parce
qu'ils sont responsables et eux ils sont
élus par leur population ils sont
responsables devant des gens qui leur
disent vous ne faites pas si vous ne
faites pas ça ils vont peut-être être
amenés à supprimer des services publics
locaux et tout ça en leur disant vous
êtes responsable électoralement devant
vos électeurs mais vous n'avez pas la
capacité financière d'agir et ça c'est
une profonde anomalie alors je partage
je le dis comme ça je resterai dans mon
temps limité la proposition des
berdoatti qu'il a fait
devant l'Association des Maires
d'Île-de-France pourquoi pas mes chers
collègues envisager il y a le PLF il y a
le PLFSS et bien faisons un FCL un PLF
des collectivités locales ça donnerait
de la visibilité à ce qu'on fait au
niveau des finances locales et ça nous
remet très peut être à l'équilibre avec
l'État pour négocier les capacités
financières et l'autonomie de nos
collectivités merci
[Applaudissements]
cher collègues et la parole est
maintenant à Emmanuel Capu pour les
indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues on dit le Sénat
conservateur mais il est des changements
que nous accueillons bien volontiers
l'organisation d'un débat sur les
finances locales en amont du budget
c'est en effet une nouveauté qui a tout
pour nous plaire
la réforme de la loi organique des lois
de finances il y a un an on a fait un
jalon du début du débat budgétaire c'est
une première c'est l'opportunité pour
nous avant de rentrer dans le dur des
discussions de faire le point sur la
situation des collectivités
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur le
sujet présenté en commission la semaine
dernière a posé un diagnostic clair et
ouvert des pistes de réforme dont chacun
peut s'emparer
l'autre particularité de ce débat c'est
qu'il intervient en début de quinquennat
et donc au début d'une nouvelle séquence
politique nos discussions ne peuvent à
cet égard faire l'impasse sur le
programme du président de la République
qui a été réélu le président de la
République s'est engagé à poursuivre le
chemin tracé depuis la crise sanitaire
et le plan de relance
en baissant les impôts de production
notamment la CVAE
ce n'est pas spontanément le souhait le
plus partagé parmi les élus locaux que
nous sommes
nous aurons tout loisir pendant l'examen
du PLF de débattre des modalités
techniques et du des calendriers de mise
en œuvre de cette suppression mais ce
débat est l'occasion de prendre un peu
de hauteur et de discuter des grandes
orientations que nous souhaitons donner
à la réforme de la fiscalité locale je
rappellerai donc d'abord pourquoi nous
sommes favorables par principe à la
réduction des impôts de production
en 2020 avant la baisse de la CVA ses
impôts représentaient plus de 5,3% du
PIB en France contre 2,6% dans l'Union
européenne et seulement 0,8% en
Allemagne
0,8%. alors ces impôts sont injustes
pour les entreprises parce qu'elles ne
pèse pas sur les bénéfices mais sur les
facteurs de production ils sont surtout
contre-productifs car ils pénalise tout
particulièrement les entreprises
industrielles des territoires la
suppression de ces impôts est donc une
bonne nouvelle pour notre industrie et
indirectement pour nos territoires
si cela n'affectait pas les finances des
collectivités locales je crois que le
Sénat pourrait que s'en réjouir mais
c'est notre rôle de nous assurer que
cette suppression sera aussi une bonne
nouvelle pour les collectivités or on
l'espère je partage certaines des
craintes qui ont été exprimées ici le
problème en réalité n'est pas la
suppression de cette impôts mais bien
son remplacement et sa
territorialisation vous l'avez rappelé
madame la ministre
l'affectation d'une fraction de TVA
donne certes aux collectivités des
ressources fiscales dynamiques elle est
nature à rassurer mais d'un autre côté
cela a été rappelé elle les prive d'un
levier de politique économique cette
nouvelle des possession engagée après la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
contribue à placer davantage les
collectivités sous la coupe de l'État
elle est mal vécue vous le savez pour
être élu local madame la ministre même
si la territorialisation que vous avez
annoncé permet de rassurer la
préservation de l'autonomie financière
des collectivités qui a été rappelée par
notre collègue car uchi ne doit pas se
faire aux dépens de leur autonomie
fiscale déjà réduite à peau de chagrin
je sais madame la ministre que vous
partagez cet objectif de préservation de
notre autonomie financière avec le
ministre Christophe Béchu
d'autant que les collectivités ont fait
preuve de leur capacité à tenir les
comptes Christine l'avare de la rappeler
tout à l'heure afin 2021 elle dégageait
5 milliards d'euros d'excellents
budgétaires en raison des circonstances
mais aussi parce qu'elles savent être
extrêmement prudentes
pourtant depuis ce moment
depuis cet excédent la reprise en sortie
de crise sanitaire et les tensions en
Ukraine ont tiré les coups de
fonctionnement à la hausse aujourd'hui
les élus locaux font face à des
augmentations qui les placent dos au mur
dans son rapport la Cour des comptes
propose plusieurs pistes de réformes
afin de remettre à plat le financement
des collectivités l'une de ces pistes
consiste notamment à partager la
fiscalité nationale c'est une piste qui
a la le mérite de garantir aux
collectivités des ressources dynamiques
qui suivent les cours de l'inflation
la cour propose aussi la tribuer un type
d'impôt par strate de collectivité cette
piste a le mérite aussi de clarifier les
choses mais elle ne répond pas aux
préoccupations des collectivités
l'urgence n'est pas de remettre à plat
la fiscalité l'urgence c'est de
sauvegarder l'autonomie financière des
collectivités
elles doivent garder la maîtrise de leur
destin et de leur politique
particulièrement dans les crises comme
celle de l’énergie que nous traversons
madame la ministre puisque nous sommes
dans un débat pouvez-vous nous rassurer
à ce sujet il en va de la préservation
des services publics de proximité nos
élus locaux sont naturellement inquiets
et ils attendent des engagements forts
du gouvernement je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Daniel broyer pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoires
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Madame et Monsieur la vice-présidente
madame la ministre chers collègue et
précédents orateurs ont cité tous les
chiffres je voudrais pour ma part
démarrer mon propos avec Pablo Neruda je
t'aime d'une manière inexplicable de
nature inavouable de façon
contradictoire je t'aime avec mes états
d'âmes qui sont nombreux et mes
changements d'humeur continuels c'est
une déclaration d'amour magnifique et ce
sont les mots que nous aurions aimé
entendre de la part de l'État à
l'endroit des collectivités
territoriales alors oui c'est une
vieille histoire entre l'État et des
collectivités locales une histoire
constitutionnelle marquée par 1983 et
les lois de décentralisation et depuis
elles sont là elles font preuve
d'efficacité bouclier de proximité
acteur essentiel de l'investissement
public de l'emploi des solidarités votre
gouvernement ne cesse de déclarer sa
flamme et son soutien au plus grandes
entreprises accordant des dizaines de
milliards sans contrepartie ni
écologique ni social la situation de
totale en est l'illustration
ultime et caricaturale je vous rappelle
que Total comme les 5 plus grandes
entreprises fossiles réalisent un profil
cumulé de 2600 dollars par seconde
madame la ministre les collectivités
territoriales sont des entreprises de
service public innovantes qui méritent
soutien liberté d'action et confiance
qui pendant la pandémie a organisé les
distributions de masques de colis
alimentaires l'accueil et la
désinfection des salles de classe pour
les enfants les professions prioritaires
le suivi des personnes âgées isolées ou
malades qui a mis en place des centres
de vaccination pour répondre aux enjeux
de santé publique que le président
Macron annonçait qui a rétabli le
dialogue durant la crise des gilets
jaunes qui investit dans les transports
collectifs la transition énergétique et
écologique qui permet que tiennent les
solidarités locales les collectivités
locales sont
tout puissant et vous les mettez au pain
sec quand le budget 2021 a offert 56
milliards aux entreprises du CAC 40 non
conditionnés et largement redistribué en
dividendes au nom de quoi l'État dont
les déficits de graves veut-il
contraindre les choix politiques des
collectivités dans la gestion est
équilibrée elle contribue à 70% des
investissements publics et par leur
budget de fonctionnement et le contribue
à la cohésion sociale car le
fonctionnement n'est pas un gros mot
c'est l'outil nécessaire des services à
la population les collectivités locales
sont le laboratoire de politique
publique innovantes et des transitions
pour notre pays transport pro bâtiment
économe en énergie renaturation des
villes développement des énergies
renouvelables protection des forêts des
littoraux de la biodiversité sont au
cœur des dynamiques portées par nos
territoires la diversité de leur
politique permet des expériences
fructueuses si vous leur donniez la
confiance mais sans le contrat madame la
ministre vous verriez les capacités à
accompagner les défis de notre société
en termes sociaux et écologique vous
mettez en place un bouclier tarifaire
pour tous les citoyens même les plus
riches d'entre nous pour les entreprises
et rien pour permettre aux collectivités
de continuer à chauffer les écoles les
collèges les lycées les équipements
sportifs les médiathèques ou les
théâtres les centres de santé ou les
crèches rien d'ailleurs pour les
hôpitaux non plus autre sujet essentiels
laissez les moduler le versement
mobilité pour faire face aux enjeux du
transport en commun laissez-les taxer
plus Airbnb des résidences secondaires
les logements vacants les hôtels de luxe
pour faire face à la crise du logement
en zone touristique la Cour des comptes
a fait des propositions suite à la
saisie de notre excellente commission
des finances les associations d'élus
portent haut et fort une contribution
responsable et le Parlement dans notre
chambre comme à l'Assemblée nationale
vous invite à nous entendre pas
seulement à nous écouter mais bien à
nous entendre entendez nous entendez-les
de supprimer pas la CVAE indexer la DGF
taxez ceux qui font des profits
exceptionnels dans ce contexte de crise
et financer ainsi un bouclier tarifaire
pour toutes les institutions publiques
supprimer les contrats mais faites
confiance à celles et ceux qui au
quotidien sont au service de nos
concitoyens et incarne le service public
de proximité cessez le désarmement
financiers de l'État et des
collectivités et oser
oser la confiance aux équités ce
jacobinisme surplombant pour un vrai
partenariat avec les collectivités
locales
osez la République décentralisée les
élus territoriaux ne veulent pas devenir
des sous-préfet anémiés qui savent ce
qu'il faudrait pour leur territoire mais
ne sont plus sont tout juste bons à
expliquer alors concitoyens qui ne
peuvent pas le faire
la parole est maintenant à Didier
Rambaud du groupe RDPI pour 6 minutes
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier notre président Claude Raynal
qui a demandé en janvier dernier à la
Cour des comptes une enquête sur les
finances locales les conclusions nous
ont été présentées la semaine dernière
et elle nous permet de prendre un peu de
hauteur dans ce débat car derrière ce
débat ne touchons au principe les plus
structurants de l'organisation de notre
République depuis la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2003 les
collectivités territoriales ont pris une
place prépondérante dans cette
organisation notre Constitution
reconnaît désormais la décentralisation
comme l'un de ses principes fondateurs
et consacre le caractère prioritaire de
leur action et le principe de
subsidiarité c'est ainsi que la question
de leur financement devient fondamentale
pour l'efficacité de l'action publique
pour l'égalité entre les territoires et
entre les citoyens au fond nous pouvons
pas dissocier la question du financement
de celle des compétences le premier
président de la Cour des comptes a
rappelé la semaine dernière que le
système de financement des collectivités
est à bout de souffle qu'il était
illisible
visible pour les responsables locaux
pour les contribuables avec des
inégalités qui se creusent entre
certains territoires et ce n'est pas un
fait nouveau il y a 13 ans la cour
dressée le bilan réforme territoriales
et l'enchevêtrement des compétences
qu'elle relevé alors préfigure la
sédimentation budgétaire que nous
constatons aujourd'hui et les
soufflement d'un modèle de financement
l'introduction de la clause de
compétences générale a conduit à
accélérer ce processus avec des
transferts qui se sont opérés de façon
désordonnée et par à coup la cacophonie
budgétaire est souvent la conséquence
des hésitations et où des
tergiversations du législateur et des
changements de doctrine de
l'administration on finance par
prélèvement sur les recettes de l'État
l'affectation d'une nouvelle compétence
puis on prévoit une rétrocompensation
quelques années plus tard car la
compétence se retrouve affectée ailleurs
à la fin plus personne de s'y retrouve
il y a 13 ans la Cour des comptes
rappelait que la nouvelle de
décentralisation lancée en 2003 aurait
pu être l'occasion d'un nouveau départ
mais déjà l'échec était flagrant aux
yeux des sages et les gouvernements de
droite comme de gauche qui se sont
succédés ont échoué très en plus tard le
constat sur les finances locales rejoint
celui posé sur les compétences alors si
nous voulons débattre de ce sujet il
nous faut nous mettre d'accord sur le
constat je me contenterai de rappeler
les éléments présentés la semaine
dernière pour la cour les collectivités
locales ont connu un excédent de 4,7
milliards d'euros fin 2021 en raison
d'une dynamique des recettes très
supérieure à celle des dépenses c'est
une situation qui contraste très
nettement avec la situation des autres
administrations publiques et la crise
sanitaire a renforcé cet écart en 2021
l'état porte la quasi-totalité du
déficit à 89% alors que les
collectivités locales sont en excédent
c'est la conséquence d'un fort soutien
de l'État tout au long de la crise mais
également des réformes successives de la
fiscalité locale compensée par des
ressources pérennes et dynamiques mais
ne nous y trompons pas derrière cette
question nous sommes face à un véritable
choix de doctrine qui devra s'imposer
dans les années qui viennent et les
scénarios de la cour permettent
d'empaiser les conséquences la liberté
qui va avec le levier de fiscalité
locale s'accompagne nécessairement d'un
recul de l'État dans son rôle de garant
de la stabilité des ressources des
collectivités nous devrons donc faire
des choix Philippe Seguin alors
président premier président de la Cour
des comptes affirmait déjà je cite
considéré qu'il est trois acteurs
autonomes de même niveau l'état la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
locales n'est pas réaliste en réalité
l'État est le seul maître du jeu car
précisément il fixe les règles du jeu
les finances publiques sont en tout et
l'État porte la responsabilité pleine et
entière de leur évolution pour nous
parlementaires et citoyen cela veut dire
trois choses la première c'est que dans
un contexte de contraintes fortes sur
nos finances publiques chacun doit
prendre sa part du rétablissement des
comptes de la Nation et toute réforme
des finances locales devra prendre en
compte ce juste équilibre entre l'État
et les collectivités locales dans la
réduction du déficit élu de nos
territoires nous devons jamais oublier
la responsabilité collective qui nous
incombe vis-à-vis des finances de la
nation la seconde et c'est ce
qu'affirmer le premier président toute
réforme d'ampleur devra se faire en
concertation avec les élus cela nous
oblige à laisser de côté nos querelles
du moment pour discuter avec
responsabilité du juste niveau
d'organisation et de l'adéquation des
ressources aux besoins là encore le
rapport de 2009 et sans appel sur les
échecs du passé pour atteindre une
véritable péréquation il aurait fallu
accepter de remettre en cause certaines
situations acquises mais cela n'a pas
été fait et je cite le premier président
à l'époque l'objectif de péréquation et
rester secondaire dans ce contexte et
tributaire des erreurs du passé ce pélèf
2023 apporte la seule réponse possible
sans recours à une réforme radicale je
pense à l'annonce par la première
ministre confirmé par Madame cailloux
maintenant de l'augmentation de la DGF
pour compenser les variations à la
baisse qu'auraient pu entraîner la
péréquation il s'agissait de trouver la
la solution la plus équilibrée pour
compenser les variations annuelles et
préserver nos collectivités sans peser
lourdement sur nos finances publiques la
troisième enfin c'est d'accepter de
revoir en profondeur le système de
péréquation pour mettre fin aux
inégalités de destin et rétablir
l'égalité entre les territoires je cite
à nouveau le premier président dans sa
présentation de 2009 la République c'est
la solidarité nationale et il ne
faudrait pas que la décentralisation
devienne la Libye de son affaiblissement
la France a eu besoin d'un pouvoir fort
et centralisé pour ce faire elle a
aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire
une question qui doit dès lors nous
occuper et celles de l'équilibre entre
le principe d'autonomie financière
consacré au plan constitutionnel
l'équité et la cohésion entre les
territoires et la responsabilité de
chacun vis-à-vis de nos finances
publiques
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Isabelle
briquet pour le groupe socialiste
écologique républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
les finances locales sont-elles devenues
les variables d'ajustement des comptes
publics
de contrat de Cahors impact de confiance
l'autonomie financière et la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales ne seront bientôt plus que
de lointains souvenirs
madame la ministre comprenez
l'inquiétude des élus locaux qui de
crises en crise doivent toujours faire
plus avec moins du fait des incessantes
modifications de ressources que vous
leur imposez suppression de la taxe
d'habitation sous le précédent
quinquennat suppression de la CVAE sous
celui-ci etc transformer ainsi des
recettes fiscales en dotation posent
problème à plusieurs niveaux c'est une
perte d'autonomie effective c'est couper
le lien avec le territoire
et les habitants et c'est acté de fait
une diminution des recettes
l'inquiétude se transforme en colère
lorsque ces mêmes élus entendent ici et
là que les finances locales se portent
bien
c'est d'ailleurs ce que m'avait répondu
le ministre des comptes publics lorsque
je l'avais alerté sur ce sujet en mars
dernier il est vrai qu'il était alors
question d'une ponction de 10 milliards
d'euros sur les finances locales
depuis avec l'augmentation du point
d'indice augmentation nécessaire la
hausse du coût des matières premières
des denrées alimentaires et de l'énergie
les collectivités locales sont au bord
de l'asphyxie enfin celle qui peuvent
encore respirer
prenons l'exemple d'une commune que je
connais bien pour l'avoir administré
pendant 20 ans comment peut-elle faire
face à une augmentation d'un million
d'euros d'électricité alors que son
budget de fonctionnement dépasse à peine
les 5 millions d'euros
beaucoup d'autres communes petites
ouvrantes rurales comme urbaine doit
faire face à la même situation il en est
de même pour les départements dont les
finances sont déjà impactées par le
manque de compensation des dépenses
liées au Ségur et aux allocations
individuelles de solidarité
particulièrement le RSA pour lequel le
fond d'urgence ne fera pas la maille
ou de la même de leurs dépenses propres
les collectivités doivent aussi faire
face aux difficultés des organismes ou
établissements qu'elle finance la
situation des EHPAD est particulièrement
préoccupantes et que dire de celles des
10 nous voyons bien cette crise
financière a des répercussions sur
l'ensemble des services publics devant
l'explosion des coûts nous avons voté
cet été un filet de sécurité si
initialement il est essentiel concerner
22 000 communes seul un tiers d'entre
elles y serai éligible il est donc
urgent de revoir la copie
notamment les critères d'accès afin
qu'ils puissent jouer pleinement son
rôle
la réponse du gouvernement doit être à
la hauteur de l'enjeu aujourd'hui que
nous proposez-vous les pactes de
confiance
quel que soit la manière dont on les
nomme ces pacte constitue une double
peine pour les collectivités baisse des
dotations du fait de la non-indexation
sur l'inflation d'une part et contrôle
de la dépense d'autre part
il s'agit purement et simplement d'un
contrat Léonard
au-delà de tout autre considération
comment imposer une réduction des
dépenses à des collectivités qui ne
peuvent en raison de l'inflation estimer
leur coût
pour la seule électricité selon des
dates d'échéance des marchés les choix
énergétiques passées les modes
d'indexation les surcoûts peuvent être
de 10 sans 300 voir un 500% même plus
dans certains endroits
de même difficile d'avoir un peu de
visibilité sur les intérêts des dettes
sauf à pouvoir prévoir les taux de 2023
dont personne ne peut à ce jour
connaître l'évolution
ainsi empoter amputé de toutes marge de
manœuvre quelle perspective reste-t-il
aux collectivités
contribuer au seul redressement des
comptes publics c'est oublier le rôle
primordial des collectivités en matière
d'investissement public
l'investissement qui assure la bonne
tenue du tissu économique local et
contribue à la préservation de l'emploi
c'est oublier le rôle majeur que je
voulais collectivités dans notre pays et
les actions qu'elles portent au
quotidien au plus près des populations
en finançant des services publics de
proximité en tout point du territoire
madame la ministre les communes les
intercommunalités les départements et
les régions n'en peuvent plus être si
peu considérés nos collectivités locales
ont besoin de vrais relations de
confiance avec l'État et non pas d'une
mise sous tutelle déguisée
merci chers collègues et
la parole est maintenant à Pascal
Savoldelli
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
c'est le président madame la ministre
ce débat sur les finances locales
intervient dans un climat madame la
ministre de défiance défiance
réciproques entre l'État tutélaire et
les collectivités asphyxiées par la
hausse de leur coup de fonctionnement ça
a été dit par beaucoup ici l'énergie les
dents alimentaires la revalorisation du
point d'indice et la hausse du coup des
matériaux menace directement les projets
d'investissement la colère des mers est
partout nous la soutenons elle sorte à
des préfets démunis les garants de la
puissance publique dans les territoires
sont sans solution le gouvernement
invite les collectivités à la sobriété
mais il est temps de prendre la mesure
des responsabilités la sobriété mais
pour qui un paradoxe un paradoxe que la
relance de l'économie soit mise à mal
par des mécanismes de marché déraisonnés
alors que les collectivités sont les
premiers investisseurs publics français
un paradoxe entretenu par une relation
financière et politique insère entre
l'État et la démocratie locale les élus
communaux puisque jamais les conseillers
départementaux et régionaux consacrent
le plus clair de leur temps à devoir
quémander leurs dieux à l'état quémander
des dotations qui ne viennent pas ce
phénomène s'est accru à cause du
démantèlement de la fiscalité locale
mais en œuvre dans le précédent
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
l'ensemble des Français a marqué une
première atteinte grave à l'autonomie
fiscale des collectivités la baisse des
impôts dit de production en est une
deuxième achevée par une suppression
totale de la CVA sur les deux prochaines
années ces deux réformes ont affaibli en
même temps l'État les collectivités
locales mais aussi et surtout la
relation entre le citoyen contribuable
son territoire et l'activité économique
pire encore les ménages les travailleurs
modestes en particulier sont ceux qui
financent des baisses d'impôts qu'ils ne
payaient pas
et ça c'est une vérité madame la
ministre alors que 93% des ressources de
TVA assisent principalement sur la
consommation de tous les ménages et les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés
étaient destinés à l'état en 2017 cette
part a diminué pour atteindre 50,6% 2021
chaque année ce sont donc 41 milliards
qui échappent à l'état et sans cet
évaporation fiscale le déficit du budget
général serait résorbé de près d'un
tiers l'état procède un transfert de
fiscalité en s'employant avec peu de
succès à éponger sa dette sur le dos des
collectivités territoriales nous ne le
rappellerons jamais assez elles sont à
l'équilibre toujours malgré et envers
tout malgré les transferts de
compétences malgré les baisses de charge
malgré la disparition de la principale
part de fiscalité économique ces
renoncements sont ceux de gouvernement
successifs et pourtant ce sont les PME
et les travailleurs qui devraient payer
pour compenser cette forme de l'acheter
cette accélération sans précédent de la
quasi disparition de l'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités puisent un début
d'encouragement dès la loi de finances
rectificative pour 1982 dans laquelle
l'État a institué et pris en charge des
allègements de la part salaire de la
base de la taxe professionnelle des
allégements pour les ménages et sur la
taxe professionnelle lourde conséquence
puisque compensées par l'État il devient
alors le premier contribuable local la
démocratie tourne sur elle-même quand le
contribua perd de vue l'utilité de ses
prélèvements sociaux et fiscaux dès 2010
le Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
relevaient je le cite une comptabilité
de plus en plus compromise entre d'une
part une évolution du dispositif par des
aménagements à la marge successifs et
sédimenté et d'autre part les objectifs
d'efficacité économique de rendement
budgétaire d'équité sociale et
d'acceptabilité politique fin de
citation la situation que nous
connaissons et l'aboutissement d'une
logique qui conduit nos collectivités
dans le mur
je peux faire que des perdants dès lors
que les collectivités constatent une
décorrélation entre leur charge et leur
capacités budgétaires le fruit
décompensations dépassé par l'évolution
démographique par une inflation qui
Hérode en euros constant s'est transfert
et par des besoins sociaux et
environnementaux nouveaux face à la
hausse de prix de l'énergie et la
décision du gouvernement de revaloriser
seulement à 3,5% le point d'indice le
fameux filet de sécurité votez allaité
comporterait je l'entends issue ou là
des trous dans la raquette à ce niveau
là il s'agit pas de jouer au tennis avec
une raquette de ping-pong madame la
ministre 430 millions d'euros c'est son
montant ne serait-ce que le point
d'indice c'est 1,14 milliards d'euros
les factures énergétiques augmentent
elles entre 30 et 300 %, selon
l'Association des maires de France les
réponses de mon groupe sont claires
ambitieuses et responsables madame la
ministre indexé dès le budget de la DGF
sur l'inflation de faction pérenne la
demande des élus c'est la continuité des
services publics sanctuariser dans la
Constitution l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités territoriales au premier
rang desquels les communes maintenir la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises la CVAE et refondre un
impôts économique territorial avec une
liberté de taux pour les communes
élargir les tarifs réglementés de vente
de l'électricité à toutes les communes
pas qu'à certaines communes et revenir
sur la suppression annoncée des tarifs
réglementés du gaz madame la ministre
les élus locaux sont responsables et
font face et nous leur et leur
représentons et n'en déplaise au
gouvernement vous pouvez le voir là et
bah les oppositions c'est utile madame
la ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour l'Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues questionnez les finances
locales revient à s'interroger sur le
relation entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales c'est la
dernière décennie c'est relations ont
largement été bouleversées par les
réformes successives portant sur
l'organisation territoriale la fiscalité
et les concours financiers de l'Etat
dans un récent rapport sur le
financement des collectivités
territoriales la Cour des comptes
souligne l'augmentation des ratios
d'autonomie financières alors que
l'autonomie fiscale se réduit
l'automnemi financière croit pour des
raisons mathématiques et n'est
absolument pas le témoin de renforcement
des marges de manœuvre financière des
collectivités locales
quant à l'autonomie fiscale elle se
réduit comme peau de chagrin
à une emprise plus forte encore de
l'État central sur les collectivités
territoriales et notamment sur les
communes après la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation ou le reversement
obligatoire d'une fraction de la taxe
d'aménagement des communes aux
intercommunalités a été annoncé par
votre gouvernement la disparition
progressive de la cave notre groupe
l'Union centriste souhaite un report de
la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme afin
de pouvoir porter le débat en profondeur
et qu'on nous fasse pas le coup de dire
qu'on porte un coup
aux entreprises il s'agit de protéger
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
locales et protéger le lien important
entre les collectivités locales et leurs
entreprises nous avons donc affaire
nouvelle fois à une fiscalité aussi par
procuration téléguidée par l'exécutif
national
et alors que la libre administration des
collectivités est toujours et encore
structurellement grignoter les
contraintes progressent toujours dans
son rapport publié ce mois-ci la Cour
des comptes indique l'évolution des
dépenses de ces dernières deux ennemi
2,4% des dépenses fonctionnement 2021
s'explique en partie par la croissance
des compétences des collectivités sous
l'effet de la décentralisation or la
réalité s'avère bien plus complexe cette
tendance s'explique par une triple
évolution la multiplication des normes
imposées aux collectivités locales un
milliard d'euros sur le projet de loi de
finance dont on va discuter dans
quelques semaines je rappelle que
l'indexation de la DGF équivaudrait à un
milliard de d'euros de dépenses
complémentaires il faut effectivement
comparer les choses deuxième cause les
largement des périmètres des
intercommunalités qui a conduit il faut
le rappeler à une forte hausse des coûts
mais également le rôle croissant de
l'échelon local pour amortir les impacts
des crises écologiques économiques et
sanitaires je pense en particulier au
covid car oui ne l'oublions pas mes
chers collègues nos communes
intercommunalités départements région
assure le dernier kilomètre de la vie de
nos concitoyens elle porte ses rapports
70% d'investissement public avec moins
pour cent moins de 9 % de la charge de
la dette
l'exécutif a également appelé récemment
à la mise en place d'un énième pack de
confiance en soi nous pourrons être
d'accord avec cette proposition mais
cela ne doit pas se traduire par
l'instauration de contrats léonien comme
ça a été dit par une collègue
précédemment si le premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron fut décevant en
matière de décentralisation à l'image de
la décevante loi 3DS et parfois houleux
concernant les relations avec les
collectivités territoriales ce pack doit
être envisagé comme un facteur d'aide à
la croissance et non pas comme un outil
de contrainte de la gestion locale pour
cela il faut fixer des objectifs communs
en laissant des libertés locales
permettant à chaque territoire de les
atteindre selon des circonstances
locales plus encore j'en appelle à la
différenciation territoriale et à la
confiance envers les élus par exemple à
court terme la révision des valeurs
locatives doit prendre en compte le taux
d'inflation indispensable à la
sécurisation des ressources locales
entre illustrations
également le financement nécessaire à la
mise en œuvre d'usaz est une variable à
intégrer dans les discussions afin
qu'elles soient comptabilisées dans les
futurs concours financiers de l'État
madame la ministre nous allons ouvrir le
débat sur le PLF je souhaite que ce
débat se fasse dans la confiance en
direction des collectivités locales mais
aussi en leur assurant les moyens de
pouvoir agir pour le dernier kilomètre
auquel nos concitoyens sont
particulièrement sensibles je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Jean-Baptiste blanc
pour le groupe républicains pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le rapport sur les
finances publiques locales annexé au
projet de loi de finance c'est un
document de 208 pages riches en chiffres
et en information mais en effet merci
Jean-Michel Arnaud quasiment rien sur la
règle nouvelle qui soulève des
inquiétudes considérables dans de
nombreux territoires en fusion souvent
celle du Zéro artificialisation nette
que nous appellerons le zan cette règle
a été définie sans les outils qui
permettrait d'en assurer la mise en
oeuvre laissant les collectivités
démunis face à un tel écart entre
l'objectif qu'il aurait assigné et les
moyens à leur disposition je veux
alerter le gouvernement une nouvelle
fois sur cette question est relayer les
inquiétudes très nombreuses nous ne font
pas tous les élus locaux sur tous les
bancs et que j'ai constaté tout
particulièrement en faisant un tour de
France un département sur deux quasiment
avec sur la mise en oeuvre du zan la
quasi absence du mot artificialisation
dans les différents rapports du
gouvernement et caractéristiques de
l'insuffisance réflexion du gouvernement
sur la manière dont les obligations
données aux collectivités seront fin
première piste est certes celle du fond
friche il a révélé un nombre important
de dossiers qui pouvait émerger pour
revitaliser les espaces délaissés et
auxquels il manquait seulement un
équilibre économique que devient le fond
friche le président de la République a
annoncé sa pérennisation vous en avez
parlé aussi d'une constitue plus que un
volet du fond d'accélération de la
transition écologique ou fond vert et
son objectif est d'imiter désormais à
1000 hectares de friches recyclées par
an et donc budgétaire n'indique pas
clairement ses crédits ce n'est pas
suffisant et les collectivités auront
besoin d'un soutien beaucoup plus
important pour mener à bien les
indispensables actions de recyclage
urbain il est nécessaire ensuite
d'appuyer également sur le levier fiscal
c'est peut-être là le message principal
la fiscalité locale n'est pas adaptée à
la politique de sobriété foncière on ne
peut pas imposer aux communes
contraintes aussi forte sur
l'aménagement local sans que les
communes en particulier est une
incitation alors qu'il réforme
successives de la fiscalité locale
distant de plus en plus le lien entre
leurs ressources et le résultat de leur
action la commission des finances a donc
saisi le Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires afin qu'il fourn cette
piste sur la manière dont la fiscalité
notamment locale pourrait favoriser
l'atteinte de l'objectif zan le CPO
présentera ses résultats le 26 octobre
et ses analyses pourront nourrir les
débats notamment sur la loi de finance
en effet plus d'un an après la
promulgation de la loi climat et
résilience les lois de finance
successives restent muettes ou presque
sur la question du financement du zan le
projet de loi de finances pour 2023
prévoit certes une adaptation mineure de
la taxe d'aménagement les collectivités
pourront exonérer des constructions
réalisées sur des sites qui ont fait
l'objet d'une opération de dépollution
cette mesure n'est de toute évidence pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu d'autant qu'il
s'agit d'une exonération facultative et
son coût pour les collectivités ne sera
pas compensé par l'État alors que
l'objectif est la mise en œuvre d'une
politique d'intérêt national la taxe
d'aménagement fait pourtant bien partie
des pistes à explorer on est donc aussi
d'autres pistes telles que la taxe sur
les logements vacants ou l'ancien
inversement pour sous densité mais aussi
des incitations directes aux
particuliers tels que le dispositif de
Normandie les dispositifs fiscaux
présentent chacun des avantages mais
aussi des risques ce contournement ou
des faits rebonds c'est pourquoi nous
aurons besoin d'aller bien de cet
éclairage du CPO dont les rapports sont
une référence je regrette que
l'administration déjà interrogée à moult
occasions n'est pas déjà conduit cette
réflexion des propositions claires sur
le financement d'usaz aurait permis
d'apaiser certaines inquiétudes sur
suscité dans les territoires les
collectivités sont en effet soumises à
des injonctions contradictoires on sait
tous désormais par coeur elles doivent
développer le logement notamment social
et attirer des activités économiques
mais sur quel terrain une enquête du
sirema et de la DCF publié mois dernier
montre que la pénurie de foncier d'ores
et déjà une réalité pour la majorité de
nos territoires mais comment peut-on
réindustrialiser la France et les
collectivités ne peuvent pas accueillir
les activités les collectivités
consacrent actuellement un travail
considérable à l'élaboration de
solutions et à la modification des
documents d'urbanisme et dans le cadre
de la mission conjointe de contrôle sur
le zan avec la présidente Valérie Letard
et les membres de la mission nous
constatons un haut niveau de réflexion
des élus et des acteurs locaux qui ont
des propositions à vous faire madame la
ministre de mise en oeuvre quantité
publiée activement doit être corrigée un
autre ministre la lui-même reconnu dans
cette hémicycle la nomenclature fait
encore l'objet de travaux des urbanistes
et un certain nombre de grands projets
engagés ou prévu risque de consommer
beaucoup trop de fonciers autorisés dans
les 10 années à venir le sujet est donc
bel et bien explosif madame madame
ministre il faut adapter en le sait tous
aussi les recettes fiscales locales aux
nouvelles missions des collectivités
locales vont celles de 37 transition
écologique et celle du zan donc aux
trois options polaires mis sur la table
par la Cour des comptes je propose d'en
rajouter une qui est celle de la
climatisation sans délai du zan et de la
fiscalité locale merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Thierry Cosic pour 4
minutes
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues au gré de nos
déplacements dans nos circonscriptions
une chose est certaine pour nos élus du
bloc communal l'inquiétude est palpable
elle est car les dépenses contraintes
des mairies s'envolent littéralement
cela peut vous paraître trivial madame
la ministre mais il faut bien que les
villes chauffent et éclairent leurs
équipements publics sur mon territoire
pour le moment métropole cela représente
4,5 millions d'euros de cours rien que
pour l'énergie
il n'est pas inutile de rappeler que nos
communes fournissent la nourriture des
restaurants scolaires est construisent
au rénove leur bâti afin d'éviter qu'ils
ne tombent en décrépitude
pourtant ce sont précisément toutes ces
dépenses liées au fonctionnement du
quotidien qui sont en aide hausse à
cause de l'inflation galopante des
matières premières
on sait déjà que pour la seule année
2022 elles vont globalement grimper de
15% pour les communes
je rappelle que chaque année les
communes doivent équilibrer leur budget
c'est cette obligation d'équilibre qui
oblige certains maires à se demander
s'ils pourront boucler leur budget 2023
sans être contraint de fermer des
services publics
dans ce contexte que fait l'état
clairement pas assez
pour une aide réellement efficiente la
DGF doit faire l'objet d'une
revalorisation à hauteur de l'inflation
je défendrai cette mesure avec mon
groupe lors de l'examen du prochain PLF
ce n'est pas la maigre rallonge de 320
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
bouchera le trou dans la raquette de la
facture énergétique du bloc communal
car je le rappelle il reste toujours
près de 900 millions d'euros non comblé
après l'aide de l'État
si nous en sommes à lutter bec et ongles
lors des débats budgétaires pour obtenir
plus de moyens c'est parce que vous avez
placé nos collectivités dans une
subjective dépendance à l'état et ce en
rognant depuis 6 ans sur leur autonomie
financière
vous avez supprimé la majeure partie des
impôts dont elle percevait les recettes
et pouvait moduler les taux
par vos réformes ou siphonner de manière
systémique les recettes plaçons ainsi de
fées les communes sous perfusion de
dotation que vous pouvez moduler de
façon discrétionnelle
je le dis sans emballage ce mode
opératoire est insupportable pour la
démocratie de proximité qui œuvre au
quotidien au sein du bloc communal
en croire les déclarations récentes de
Bruno Le Maire cela ne semble pas aller
en s'améliorant
interroger sur la gestion financière des
communes en difficulté il a déclaré en
septembre dernier je cite
vous avez des collectivités bien gérées
et d'autres qui sont moins bien gérés
ces dernières ne pourront pas se
prévaloir de l'aide de l'État
cette déclaration trace les contours de
vos mal nommés pacte de confiance déjà
rejetées à l'Assemblée nationale dans
votre projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques bien que celle-ci
semble avoir peu de chance d'être voté
car rappelons vous êtes aujourd'hui
minoritaire
une chose est certain et certaines vous
êtes animés par une volonté d'entrer
dans une relation transactionnelle avec
les collectivités territoriales voire
même dans personnaliser ses relations
avec l'État
j'en appelle à tous les bancs de cette
émission un grand débat doit être mené
sur une refonte idéologique fondant la
relation état collectivité territoriale
ce débat doit sortir des contingences
matériels et budgétaires et doit être
d'une ampleur supérieure il doit
interroger notre rapport à l'impôt local
et la fonction démocratique que
représente la possibilité que ce dernier
puisse être voté et levés par nos élus
locaux
si rien n'est fait alors le gouvernement
accélérera encore la mise sous tutelle
budgétaire des collectivités
territoriales obligeant nos
collectivités à devoir à l'avenir
négocier chaque ligne budgétaire et cela
je le redis n'est ni acceptable ni
supportable
merci chers collègues la parole
à Charles gainer pour les républicains
pour 4 minutes
sera Charles gainer le dernier
intervenant
des groupes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues l'avenir des finances
des collectivités locales interpellent
dans sa dimension immédiate comme dans
ces perspectives à moyen terme
au regard du moment présent je voudrais
évoquer tout d'abord le traitement dont
elles font l'objet dans le cadre de la
loi de finance en mettant un focus
particulier sur le bloc communal
le gouvernement conforté par
l'appréciation de la Cour des comptes
vient d'évoquer leur bonne situation
financière et leurs excédents qui
friseraient l'insolence aux sortir de la
crise financière je souhaiterais nuancer
cette assertion comment justifier la
relativité de la perception les
collectivités locales ne sont pas régies
par les mêmes règles de gestion que
l'État et c'est tant mieux bordé par la
règle d'or elles ne peuvent utiliser la
dette à des fins de fonctionnement et
doivent gérer leur finances par la
pratique de mise en réserve et d'une
gestion prévisionnelle pluriannuelle il
est donc curieux que l'État observe une
lecture de leur situation à l'aune de
règles qui ne sont pas les leurs alors
qu'il devrait plutôt songer à s'en
inspirer dans leur pratique vertueuse et
s'obliger à ce qu'il entend à poser aux
autres je veux évoquer par là le contrat
dit de confiance
je rappellerai à cet égard que notre
République leur garantit pourtant la
libre administration au terme de
l'article 72 de la Constitution ainsi
que la indiquée Roger carotschi tout à
l'heure durant le quart de siècle écoulé
les collectivités ont consenti des
efforts financiers sans précédent il me
paraît de bonnes justice de les évoquer
dans obstant le fait que les fonds
qu'elles ont ainsi épargnés entre
positivement dans le sol Maastrichtien
pour le plus grand bénéfice de notre
pays
afin de permettre au pays justement de
conserver une trajectoire acceptable
elles ont ainsi renoncé progressivement
la taxe professionnelle comme à la taxe
d'habitation en contrepartie de dotation
au moins dynamique elles ont subi durant
quatre ans la contribution redressement
des finances publiques qui a amputé
drame drastiquement lors des GF pour
l'avoir ensuite figé et contributrice à
la péréquation verticale de sorte que si
on avait parade paramétré pour elle une
loi de programmation spécifique sur
cette période on constaterait que
c'était un différentiel de l'ordre 50
milliards qu'elles ont consenti à la
nation
aussi si malgré l'inflation et la crise
énergétique nous ne revendiquerons pas
pour elle l'indexation d'une DGF en état
de délices avancée et admettrons le
principe d'un filet de sécurité et de
dotation ciblée sur les plus vulnérables
nous voulons dire haut et fort que le
compte n'y est toujours pas et que c'est
un bon droit que les collectivités
n'admettent pas d'être fustigé par un
état impécunieux pour ce qui concerne
leur avenir à moyen terme il n'est rien
de dire qu'elle ne dispose d'aucune
visibilité dans un système financier
désormais menacé d'obsolescence je veux
m'en expliquer la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et la perspective de celle
de la CVAE ont totalement achevé la
désarticulation du cadre sous-tendu par
des indices désormais privés de sens et
ne dispose plus des perspectives
nécessaires pour gérer leur dynamique et
doit s'en remettre à la diligence de la
DGCL pour la mise en oeuvre d'une
péréquation au fil de l'eau
ainsi que vient de le confirmer le
rapport établi par la Cour des comptes à
la demande de notre commission des
finances le système est devenu complexe
et à bout de souffle l'école d'activités
locales sont désormais à la merci de la
suppression ou de l'affectation nouvelle
d'un appeau décidé d'en haut et ne
dispose plus d'aucune visibilité dans un
monde devenu qui plus est aléatoire et
complexe et alors qu'elles sont aux
prises avec un système financier devenu
incohérent nous nous sommes attelés au
Sénat à résoudre cette équation mais
elle est devenue un seul face au
scénariste aussi pluriel que c'est
évoqué par la Cour dans ses travaux
faute d'une boussole pour se faire il
faudrait que l'État mette fin au
démantèlement erratique des ressources
des collectivités et initie des bases du
réforme dans un dialogue construit avec
elle et dotée d'une nouvelle gouvernance
les collectivités sont un acteur majeur
de notre République au plan démocratique
et sociétal et réalise 70% de
l'investissement public elle le mérite
Madame le Ministre quand allez-vous
mettre cet ouvrage sur le métier
merci chers collègues vous étiez donc le
dernier intervenant des groupes madame
la ministre vous avez un temps de
réponse à l'ensemble des interventions
tant de réponse assez limitée puisque la
règle c'est 5 minutes vous pouvez
dépasser un peu puisque vous avez choisi
par intervenir au fil du débat mais
allez-y vous avez la parole
oui vous pouvez venir là
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
vais m'efforcer dans le temps qui m'est
dévolu de répondre à la majorité de vos
interventions je commencerai par
répondre à certains points précis qui
ont été abordés sur les mesures du PLF
2023 avant de répondre plus globalement
sur les enjeux qui ont été soulevés sur
la nécessité d'une réforme de la
fiscalité locale et sur la nécessité
d'un nouvel élan décentralisation dans
notre pays pour les questions les plus
techniques qui ont été évoquées je
reviendrai vers chacun d'entre vous pour
vous apporter une réponse circonstanciée
monsieur le sénateur qui a pu sur la
CVAE comme j'ai pu le dire dans mon
intervention luminaire la suppression sa
suppression n'entraînera pas je le redis
n'entraînera pas une baisse des
ressources des collectivités
territoriales bien au contraire sa
compensation intégrale par l'attribution
d'une nouvelle fraction de TVA et de sa
dynamique garantira aux collectivités
une meilleure prévisibilité et
d'ailleurs visibilité sur leurs recettes
alors que la CVAE était très volatile
ensuite sur la compensation à l'écoute
des élus nous avons justement souhaité
introduire un mécanisme de moyenne pour
lisser la volatilité de la CVAE d'une
année à l'autre en intégrant l'année
2023 dans le calcul
la compensation l'année prochaine
compose correspondra aux sommes que
l'État aurait dû verser au collectivités
en 2023 au titre de la CVAE rien ne sera
conservé par l'État la dynamique de
cette compensation sera territorialisée
je le redis un territoire accueillant
plus d'activités recevra plus de TVA
monsieur le sénateur Cozic sur la
question de la non-indexation de la DGF
sur l'inflation je voudrais souligner
tout d'abord que le choix de ne pas
l'indexer la DGF sur l'inflation ne date
pas d'hier ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
plutôt mais des années 2010 pour autant
pour autant notre gouvernement a pris la
décision inédite depuis 13 ans
d'augmenter la DGF de 320 millions
d'euros je rappellerai qu'entre 2008 et
2014 c'est les dotations des
collectivités avaient subi une baisse de
plus de 11 milliards d'euros par
ailleurs nous avons aussi fait le choix
d'une action ciblée avec un filet de
sécurité et un bouclier faire ou encore
avec le fond d'urgence pour les communes
en difficulté financières cela nous
permet de soutenir en priorité ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin comme vous le
savez les situations de chaque
collectivité sont extrêmement diverses
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'une manière plus générale je pense que
les interventions des sénateurs gainés
et Rambaud ont permis d'offrir non pas
une synthèse exhaustive mais en tout cas
l'ensemble une synthèse de l'ensemble de
vos doutes de vos interrogations qui
reposent sur le même constat que nous
partageons tous en réalité notre modèle
des finances locales est aujourd'hui
complexe et marquée par une longue
sédimentation compte accentué les
réorganisations successives du partage
des compétences entre les différentes
strates des collectivités territoriales
une situation qui parfois peut donner
l'impression d'affecter les principes
cardinaux qui président aux finances
locales notamment l'autonomie des
collectivités territoriales comme le
souligne le rapport de la Cour des
comptes dont votre chambre a eu le rose
initiative il faut d'abord rappeler
qu'il s'agit là davantage d'une
impression que d'une réalité l'autonomie
financière telle que mesurée par les
ratios définis en 2004 progresse c'est
la part d'attribution croissante de la
fiscalité nationale au sein des
ressources propres des collectivités qui
nourrissent chez les élus le sentiment
d'une perte de maîtrise d'une
déconnexion de leurs ressources avec les
réalités du territoire je pense que le
Président de la République a été très
clair dans son discours prononcé en
Mayenne le 20 octobre sur sa volonté de
lancer le nouveau chapitre de
décentralisation dans notre pays a
besoin je crois en effet que notre
modèle est à repenser c'est-à-dire à
remettre à plat à simplifier pour qu'il
fasse nouveau sens pour chacun pour les
élus locaux comme pour nos concitoyens
il faut repenser notre système pour que
les responsabilités accompagnent à
chaque niveau le pouvoir normatif et les
financements alors bien sûr cela
impliquera nécessairement des choix
politiques forts le rapport de la Cour
des comptes le souligne des choix que
notre gouvernement est prêt à faire mais
cette réponse de notre système de
décentralisation ne peut être conduit et
le rapport de la Cour des comptes le
souligne également qu'en étroite
concertations avec l'ensemble des
parties concernées avec les
collectivités territoriales avec les
élus et avec bien sûr le Parlement avec
vous afin de parvenir à un consensus
pour l'intérêt général de notre pays
aussi je ne me prononcerai pas
aujourd'hui sur le détail du scénario
envisagé par la Cour des comptes il
s'agit d'un travail prospectif
particulièrement précieux qui alimentera
sans aucun doute le grand chantier que
nous souhaitons mener
à cet égard je vous remercie également
pour vos interventions qui nourrissent
ma réflexion personnelle sur ce sujet
mais notre démarche de co-construction
ne serait pas véritablement sincère vous
en conviendrez si nous cherchions en
amont à déterminer le débat par des
positions arrêtées nous avons bien sûr
un objectif une boussole des convictions
qui nous guideront dans nos échanges à
venir mais ce n'est en aucun cas un
schéma préconçu puisque c'est ensemble
que nous construirons le nouveau modèle
déconcentré de notre pays
monsieur le sénateur requier dans votre
intervention vous mettez en garde contre
les promesses illusoires et je suis
d'accord avec vous et je citerai
Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui n'a pas quitté
c'est bon depuis si longtemps la
politique ne peut plus promettre des
lents de mains qui chantent et repousser
toujours la résolution des problèmes du
quotidien le nouveau chapitre de
décentralisation que nous souhaitons
ouvrir n'est pas le retour d'une vieille
antienne c'est la réponse nécessaire aux
limites de notre système cette refonte
que nous souhaitons construire avec vous
impose pour tous pour l'État mais aussi
pour les collectivités de jouer le jeu
de cette remise à plat qui remettra
nécessairement en cause de nombreuses
situations établies je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci madame la ministre et pour
conclure le débat la parole est
maintenant à Christine lavardde
Vice-Présidente de la commission des
finances
merci monsieur le Président alors je
suis certaine que le rapporteur général
à qui il aurait appartenu de faire cette
conclusion aurait fait remarquer avec
malice au gouvernement nous doit avoir
un problème de dictionnaire parce
qu'après avoir expérimenté une nouvelle
définition du dialogue nous venons de
dire ce soir une nouvelle acceptation du
mot débat nous aurions je pense
certainement souhaité quelque chose de
plus interactif tel que c'était l'esprit
en tout cas de la réforme qui avait été
prévu par la loft ensuite madame la
ministre permettez-moi de vous dire qu'à
certains moments vous avez fait une
sorte de réécriture de l'histoire vous
avez même persévéré pour ce qui consiste
au filet de sécurité ce fil est sécurité
il n'a pas été voulu par le gouvernement
il a été imposé par les députés et
ensuite complété par les sénateurs au
moment du projet de loi de finances
rectificative donc je voudrais que ceci
soit bien rappelé par ailleurs également
pour ce qui concerne l'indexation des
valeurs locatives professionnelles mais
vous ne faites pas un cadeau
collectivités vous ne faites
qu'appliquer le droit depuis plusieurs
années les valeurs locatives évoluent
comme l'inflation constatée à l'indice
du novembre donc aujourd'hui vous on ne
fait juste que ce qui est prévu par la
loi alors plusieurs intervenants ici ont
rappelé et notamment par exemple Pascal
salvadelli des erreurs de votre de la
majorité à laquelle vous appartenez
désormais notamment le lien qui s'est
complètement distendu entre les usagers
des services publics locaux et le coût
de fournitures de ces services publics
locaux alors nous ici nous n'avons pas
changé puisque je me rappelle avec
émotion que c'était l'objet de ma
première question d'actualité dans ce
gouvernement en octobre 2017 donc ça
fait cinq ans que nous constatons ces
égarements et dans lesquels vous semblez
vouloir continuer avec la suppression
encore annoncée de la CVAE
alors plusieurs intervenants l'ont
demandé ici et notamment Roger caroutchi
nous avons besoin les collectivités ont
besoin d'une certaine visibilité à moyen
long terme pour pouvoir mener des
projets pour pouvoir s'engager cette
visibilité pourtant l'ancien
gouvernement nous l'avait annoncé
puisque je me souviens encore que dans
l'audition de ministre à la commission
des finances quand on demandait par
exemple l'affectation d'une partie des
recettes de la TICPE au collectivités
locales pour venir financer les dépenses
de transition écologique on ne répondait
c'est pas le bon moment attendez la loi
de financement des collectivités locales
alors cette loi elle n'est jamais
arrivée plusieurs ici viennent encore de
vous la réclamer ce soir alors madame la
ministre je sais que vous ne pouvez pas
être insensible au courage de la vérité
que les sénateurs ont eu ici ce soir les
différents orateurs ont exquisé des
pistes d'évolution pour les textes
budgétaires à venir
alors le rapporteur général qui a suivi
tous débats depuis chez lui vous fait
passer un message il me fait dire que si
vous savez écouter la chambre haute
alors tout devient possible
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 22h pour
l'examen de la proposition de loi
encadrant l'intervention des cabinets de
conseils privés dans les politiques
publiques la séance est suspendue